update the increased demand for cova
testing the health department is opening
up more locations one of them texas
station which actually began about an
hour ago that's where mary jane belliesa
joins us live and mary jane i understand
you need an appointment prior to showing
up there
yeah that's absolutely right christian
again this is not first come first serve
you do need an appointment and even
though this location opened up at 3 pm
the lines they were starting as early as
2 30.
covid testing is now open at the texas
station for 21 days to help expand the
need clark county commissioner william
mccurdy ii says this location
specifically serves the needs for people
living in the northwest valley
administering an additional 4 thousand
tests per day the highest number of
positive cova positivity positivity
rates are coming from right here in
89108
which is also strategically why clark
county along with our our state and
federal partners decided collectively to
make sure that we set up a drive-through
testing operation here while this is a
temporary site north las vegas deputy
fire chief travis anderson says it's
possible the site could stay open longer
if cases continue to rise
now you can access testing on the first
floor of the texas station parking
garage on texas lane while this did open
up at three today hours moving forward
will be from noon to eight that's
wednesday through sunday and again you
do need an appointment you can find that
link on our website at eight newsnow dot
com reporting live out here at texas
station mary jane ballezza live local
now
mary jane thank you for that and we want
to remind you that we've gathered all
coveted information in one place that's
eight newsnow dot com and here's an easy
and fast way to get there just point
your cell phone camera at the qr code
right there in the middle of your screen
click on the link that pops up it'll
take you to the website for a number of
helpful resources